Ich will nicht, ich sage mal, mit einem
Impfstoff geimpft werden, der in einem
Land hergestellt wird, wo irgendein
Potentat sozusagen sagt: Ich nutze jetzt
auch das freigegebene Patent und mache
jetzt auch Impfstoffe, die in der Qualität
nicht entsprechen, wo keiner mehr
kontrollieren kann, was da Sache ist.
Wunderbar, schön, dass ihr es einrichten
konntet. Vielen Dank dafür.
Heute coronabedingt seid ihr nur zu viert
auf dem Feld. Passt ja auch ganz gut
zum Thema. 13 Fragen, hier kommt die erste:
Müssen wir Impfpatente freigeben,
um die Corona-Pandemie zu beenden?
Wenn ihr sagt ja, es ist zwar hart,
aber notwendig, dann würde ich euch
bitten geht bitte aufs grüne Feld.
Und wenn ihr sagt nein, das schadet
vielleicht sogar, dann bitte aufs gelbe
Feld und bitte. Vielen Dank! Jetzt
wissen wir, wo ihr steht. Aber wo steht
ihr eigentlich? Wir in Deutschland
diskutieren ja gerade darüber,
was Geboosterte dürfen und wann die vierte
Impfung kommt. Und das, während Milliarden
Menschen auf der Welt noch nicht mal
ihre erste Spritze erhalten haben. Das birgt
in allererster Linie natürlich
Gefahr für die Gesundheit derjenigen, aber
auch die Gefahr für neue
Virusmutationen und damit für eine ewige Verlängerung
der Pandemie. Impfdosen müssen also
auch schneller zu denjenigen Menschen,
die das Pech haben, nicht in einem
reichen Land zu leben. Soweit sind sich viele
weitgehend einig. Die Frage ist aber:
Wie kriegen wir das hin? Und das diskutieren
wir nicht nur bei 13 Fragen, das wird
gerade weltweit diskutiert. Ist doch ganz
einfach, sagen die einen. Gebt die Impfung
Patente frei, bringt das Know how
und die Technologie dorthin, wo Impfstoffe
gebraucht werden und wo man Impfstoffe
produzieren muss. Na ja, so einfach
ist es nun auch nicht, sagen die anderen,
denn das würde die Forschung
radikal ausbremsen. Und wer sollte noch
Innovationen entwickeln, wenn er weiß,
am Ende wird eh alles verschenkt? Also
die Fronten sind geklärt. Die Frage
heute wird sein: Schaffen wir es, Brücken
zu bauen? Also gibt es eine Art
Zwischenlösung, vielleicht sogar einen
Kompromiss. Das werden wir am Ende
dieser Folge sehen. Jetzt erst mal die Frage
an euch: Wo würdet ihr euch
positionieren? Auf dem grünen oder auf dem gelben Feld?
Und warum? Jetzt geht's los.
Grundsätzlich gilt wie immer, wenn ihr der Gegenseite
in einem Punkt zustimmt, dann könnt
ihr gerne einen Schritt auf sie zugehen,
wenn ihr sagt: Grundsätzlich finde ich gar
nicht so schlecht, was du sagst, aber
in dem Fall, ist das totaler
Quatsch, könnt ihr auch gerne einen Schritt
nach hinten gehen. Mein Ziel
am Ende dieser Folge sollte es sein,
möglichst viele von euch hier vorne
in der Mitte im sogenannten Kompromissfeld
zu versammeln. Mal sehen, ob ihr das heute
hinkriegt. Ich bin sehr gespannt.
13 Fragen, hier kommt Frage Nummer
zwei und die geht an Stephan. Du hast ja einen
relativ guten Überblick über die internationale
Gesundheitslage auch nicht
zuletzt in ärmeren Ländern. Warum ist
es aus deiner Sicht so wichtig, die Patente
-freizugeben?
-Wir werden uns der Pandemie nicht
rauskommen, wenn nicht weltweit viel,
viel mehr Menschen oder auch alle Menschen
im Grunde genommen Zugang zu Impfungen
haben. Und momentan brauchen wir einfach
mehr Impfstoff. Wir brauchen ihn
jetzt, schnell, aber die Hersteller kommen
mit der Produktion nicht nach. Die Freigabe
von Patenten wäre ein Instrument,
mit dem man ermöglichen würde, dass mehr
Hersteller, Impfstoffe produzieren könnten
und somit auch mehr Impfstoff zur Verfügung
stehen würde. Wir befinden uns
in dieser Pandemie in einem
absoluten Ausnahmezustand und wir müssen hier
wirklich jedes Instrument nutzen, das uns
zur Verfügung steht. Und die Kosten,
die Corona für die Menschen
weltweit bedeutet, für die Wirtschaft, aber
auch für die für die persönliche
Gesundheit sind so hoch,
dass sie tatsächlich Gewinn- und Profitinteressen
in den Schatten stellen.
Klingt doch wahnsinnig
plausibel, Manfred, warum stimmst du nicht zu?
Ich stimme deshalb nicht zu, weil ich in der Sache
zwar grundsätzlich die Ansicht
teile, dass wir dieses Problem nur lösen
können, wenn wir weltweit tatsächlich
allen Menschen eine Impfung
zukommen lassen. Das bedeutet, wir müssen
tatsächlich in kurzer Zeit Milliarden
von Impfdosen produzieren. Aber dabei muss
sichergestellt sein: Wirksamkeit,
Unbedenklichkeit und die pharmazeutische
Qualität dieser Impfungen. Es ist
niemandem geholfen, wenn wir, ich sage
mal, zwei drittklassige Impfstoffe
haben, die nicht nach den Regularien,
wie wir sie kennen, hergestellt
werden. Wir sollten die Impfpatente nicht
freigeben, weil diese Patente
die Grundlage dafür sind,
dass wir diese Pandemie überwinden
werden können. Erst mithilfe dieser Patente
konnten wir Impfstoffe in den Markt,
in die Therapie einführen. Und das muss
-konsequent fortgesetzt werden.
-Jetzt argumentieren ja zum Beispiel
Unternehmen: Wenn wir jetzt
Patente freigeben, dann verlieren
wir das Vertrauen in Patente
insgesamt und keiner hätte mehr Lust,
irgendwas Innovatives
herzustellen. Haben die Unternehmen recht?
Ich glaube, die haben recht. Wir müssen
uns daran erinnern, dass beispielsweise
das Mainzer Unternehmen, das diesen berühmten
Impfstoff entwickelt hat,
im Grunde in seiner Entwicklung -
es ging ja zunächst um Tumorimpfstoffe -
eigentlich schon so etwas wie am Abgrund
stand. Und erst über das Investment
von Privatpersonen ist dieses Unternehmen
in die Lage gekommen, weiterzuarbeiten,
weiter zu forschen, um dann im richtigen
Moment diesen Impfstoff zu entwickeln.
Hätte es damals die Perspektive
nicht gegeben, dass wenn da was rauskommt,
das auch patentgeschützt ist,
hätten wir den Impfstoff nicht zur Verfügung.
Daran müssen wir uns erinnern.
Wer nimmt das Risiko in die Hand? Gerade
im pharmazeutischen Bereich, wo die Trauben
hoch hängen, das Risiko einzugehen
viel Geld in die Hand zu nehmen, um etwas zu entwickeln,
wenn am Ende nicht
auch die Möglichkeit
hat, daran zu verdienen.
Aber was du sagst ist also: das Patent
ist nicht das Problem, sondern Teil
der Lösung. So ist es. Evein
gehst du ein paar Schritte auf ihn zu?
Gerade bin ich ein paar
Schritte eher zurückgegangen aus dem Grund,
weil ich nicht glaube, dass es nur die Investitionen
Einzelner sind,
sondern dass es ja schon
auch die öffentliche Hand ist,
die Forschungseinrichtungen
finanziert, dass es auch sehr, sehr viel
Grundlagenforschung braucht, die nicht
einzig und alleine über Pharmaunternehmen
finanziert wird. Deshalb kann ich tatsächlich
da nicht in Gänze mitgehen.
Das Beispiel Patente, Impfen und globale
Gerechtigkeit beim Thema Corona ist
ein weiteres Beispiel, was zeigt,
dass koloniale Strukturen unsere Gesellschaft
weiter durchziehen. Und ich wünsche
mir, dass wir dieses Thema angehen, auf vielen
verschiedenen Ebenen. Über Patente
zu diskutieren. Und was für alternative
Möglichkeiten es gibt, ist auf jeden
Fall ein Weg und ein wichtiger Schritt
von vielen. Und ich sehe natürlich
den Aspekt, dass es sehr, sehr wichtig ist,
Anreize zu schaffen. Aber ich glaube
eben im Zentrum sollte das Menschenrecht
auf Gesundheit am Ende immer
stehen und nicht die Profitmaximierung.
Und ich glaube, wir bewegen uns da auf so
einem Spektrum von sehr, sehr viel Gewinn.
Und Patente freigeben bedeutet nicht
gar kein Gewinn mehr für Pharmakonzerne,
sondern eben weniger. Und deshalb kann
ich glaube ich nicht so richtig vorgehen.
Ich kann es argumentativ
nachvollziehen, bin aber nicht ganz bei dir.
Aber Bernhard ist schon einen
guten Schritt nach vorne gegangen. Warum?
Es ist absolut richtig, dass wir ein Menschenrecht
auf Gesundheit haben, es ist
absolut richtig, dass wir für alle
Zugang zu Impfstoffen brauchen, und zwar schnell.
Das ist nicht nur internationale
Solidarität, sondern es ist
das Eigeninteresse, damit die Pandemie
schnell zu Ende kommt. Da ist, glaube ich,
ein großer Konsens. Die Frage
bei den Impfstoff-Patenten ist wirklich
die Abwägung zwischen Investitionsschutz
und Innovationsschutz gegenüber viel mehr
produzieren. Und wir sagen dieser Innovations-
und Investitionsschutz ist
der Schlüssel dafür, dass wir weiter
forschen an Medikamenten. Wir streiten
vielleicht nur über den Weg dahin und wir sind
der Meinung, die Bundesregierung ist
der Meinung, dass wir andere
Instrumente nutzen müssen, um diesen weltweiten Zugang
zu Impfstoffen zu gewährleisten,
und zwar schnell und für alle.
Wenn ich euch beiden richtig
verstanden habe, sagt ihr: Ja, grundsätzlich wollen
wir natürlich Patentschutz und Schutz
von geistigem Eigentum weiter
aufrechterhalten, aber wir haben eine weltweite
Ausnahmesituation. Jetzt springt
über euren Schatten und macht für ein paar
Monate die Patente frei und dann schauen
-wir weiter.
-Ja, ich glaube diese Ausnahmesituation,
die ist unzweifelhaft da. Und es gibt
ja in dem internationalen Rechtsrahmen,
dem TRIPS-Abkommen auch dafür
Vorschriften, dass ärmere Länder
in Ausnahmesituationen dann diese Patente
freigeben. Also ein Waiver ist
die Diskussion. In dieser Situation
wird es aber nicht helfen alleine. Wir brauchen
viel mehr. Und das ist eigentlich
das Ärgerliche an dieser Diskussion.
Wir versteifen uns auf die Frage
Patente und verlieren darüber hinaus den Blick
darauf, was denn eigentlich noch
notwendig ist. Ein Beispiel: Niemand ist geholfen,
wenn ein Patent freigegeben
würde. Es würde in einem afrikanischen Land
produziert und es gibt keine Behörde,
die diesen Impfstoff testen und zulassen kann.
Und das ist ein Beispiel dafür, dass wir viel
mehr tun müssen, als nur die Patente
-freizugeben.
-Gut, aber viel mehr tun als nur heißt ja
-auch, auch die Patente freigeben.
-Ja, und da sind wir wieder beim
Ausgangspunkt. Damit zerstören
wir wieder das Vertrauen in diesem Pfad
in dieses Patentsystem. Deswegen sagen
wir viel mehr tun plus freiwillige
Patent-Freigabe. Das, was wir jetzt
Patent-Patenschaft oder Partnerschaft
nennen, das ist etwas, was wir angehen
müssen, aber eben nicht
gegen die Unternehmen,
sondern mit ihnen gemeinsam.
-Überzeugt dich das Stephan.
-Vieles ist richig, was Bernhard gesagt
hat, aber es überzeugt mich nicht. Ich glaube
wir müssen da noch mal ein bisschen
zurückgehen an den Anfang. Also wir sprechen
ja nicht davon, dass wir sagen,
Patente sollen jetzt überall
flächendeckend freigegeben werden
und es soll kein Patentschutz mehr
bestehen. Der Vorschlag, der auf dem Tisch
liegt, der von über 100 Ländern
weltweit unterstützt wird, unter anderem
auch von den Vereinigten Staaten, das Abkommen,
was Bernhard schon erwähnt hat,
TRIPS, sieht vor, dass Länder die Möglichkeit
haben, in der nationalen
Gesetzgebung zu sagen für die Dauer
der Pandemie für Produkte gegen Corona -
es kann also auch Medikamente mit einschließen,
das ist, glaube ich ganz
wichtig, weil die werden jetzt immer
wichtiger werden, gelten jetzt erst mal
für die Dauer der Pandemie, die Patente
nicht. In Deutschland, in Europa,
in der EU, in Nordamerika würde das natürlich
würden das die Staaten nicht
machen. Also Deutschland
würde jetzt nicht sagen diesen Waiver,
diese Ausnahmegenehmigung, die setzen
wir jetzt in nationales Recht um. Das heißt
also, in allen
Industrienationen wäre noch genug Profit zu machen
für die Pharmafirmen und das ist ja
momentan pro Sekunde 1000 Dollar Gewinn
für die Hersteller der Vaccine, die wir momentan
gegen Covid-19 haben. Was man
aber ermöglichen würde, ist,
wenn man sagt, es gibt Länder, in denen
es Produktionskapazitäten gibt, die auch genau
auf dem Standard, den wir brauchen,
produzieren können. Die könnten
sozusagen noch zusätzlich in die Produktion
einsteigen und einfach die, die das Angebot
an Impfstoffen erhöhen.
-Direkte Antwort danach kommt Evein.
-Ja, also ganz viel richtig. Und es wäre
noch richtiger, wenn wir eine internationale
Impfstoff-Knappheit hätten,
die wir nicht mehr haben. Wir haben
ein großes Verteilungsproblem, eine große
Ungerechtigkeit im Zugang, aber der Engpass
Faktor ist nicht mehr das zu wenig
-Impfstoff produziert wird.
-Aber das Argument ist ja, wenn man
Impfstoff an verschiedenen
Produktionsstandorten herstellen könnte,
dann wäre auch das Verteilungsproblem
ein geringeres.
Der Zugang ist in der Tat dort am niedrigsten,
wo es keine Produktion gibt.
Deswegen müssen wir das ändern. Wir streiten
ja nur über freiwillig oder nicht
freiwillig in Kooperation mit der Industrie
oder gegen die Industrie.
-Antwort von dir.
-Ich wollte so vieles beantworten.
Ja, es gibt auch vieles zu beantworten.
Wir haben ja auch verschiedene
-Perspektiven hier schon ausgetauscht.
-Ja, ich versuche mal das Ganze noch mal,
also einen Schritt zurück oder eine Ebene
nach oben, und zwar durch die Brille
von strukturellen Ungleichheiten,
Rassismus und kolonialen Kontinuitäten,
weil ich glaube, es ist ganz, ganz
wichtig, dass wir das in dieser Diskussion
nicht aus dem Blick verlieren,
dass es nicht aus Zufall passiert ist,
dass diese Unternehmen in Europa
sitzen, dass es da eine große Marktmacht gibt,
sondern dass es Konsequenz ist,
kolonialer Ausbeutungsstrukturen. Es gab nicht immer
Patentrechte, die integriert wurden in die in die WTO,
sondern ist eine Entscheidung,
-die getroffen wurde-
-WTO, Welthandelsorganisation!
-und auch nicht getroffen von Ländern
des globalen Südens zwangsläufig, sondern eben
von starker Pharmalobby,
gelenkt auch durch die USA und durch
die Industriestaaten, die überhaupt
dafür gesorgt haben, dass TRIPS erst einmal Teil
der WTO. Und ich glaube, das ist schon
mal sehr, sehr wichtig in der Kontinuität
zu sehen, weil es gab damals
schon Widerstände und damals schon
Nichtregierungsorganisationen,
Aktivistinnen,
insbesondere aus den Ländern des
globalen Südens, die das kommen sehen haben,
was der Preis sein wird und der Preis
sind am Ende Menschenleben. Und man sieht
es sehr, sehr gut, wenn man noch
mal zurückschaut und sich die HIV bzw.
AIDS anguckt, was dort historisch
passiert ist. Was ist passiert? Die Preise
der entwickelten Medikamente waren
einfach so hoch, dass in Konsequenz einfach sehr,
sehr viele Menschen sich diese nicht
leisten konnten. Und ich glaube es einfach
sehr, sehr wichtig, das im Blick zu behalten
und da nicht so zurückzuschrecken
und so zu tun, als wäre es schon
immer so gewesen. Sondern dass das Patentrecht
gibt, ist eine Entscheidung, die getroffen
wurde von einem bestimmten Teil der Welt
und die so auch gewisse
Machtverhältnisse kontinuierlich aufrecht erhält und Länder
im globalen Süden auch angewiesen sind
auf Initiativen wie COVAX oder Gavi, weil man
sonst auch nichts machen kann,
sozusagen. Aber diese Entscheidung haben sie nicht
selbst getroffen. Ich glaube, es ist
sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr wichtig.
Das heißt, du schließt daraus auch wegen,
sagen wir mal einer strukturellen
Ungleichheit, die sich über -
deiner Argumentation nach - über Jahrhunderte
hinzementiert hat, wäre es jetzt an der Zeit
zu sagen: Komm, wir geben jetzt
die Patente frei. Schließlich sind
wir diejenigen, die euch ausgebeutet haben.
-Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
-Ja, ich glaube nicht nur jetzt, sondern
diese Frage stellt man sich immer
mal wieder in der Historie. Seit es,
das Patentrecht gibt. Und ich glaube,
jetzt haben wir eine globale Pandemie.
Jetzt kommt diese Frage wieder auf.
Aber das ist keine Frage, die mir eingefallen
ist, sondern es ist eine Frage, die uns
schon seit Jahrzehnten beschäftigt.
Jetzt die Frage an euch: Raucht euch
auch schon der Kopf? Oder seid ihr ein bisschen
schlauer geworden? Auf welcher Seite
würdet ihr euch jetzt gerade
positionieren? Schreibt uns gerne
in die Kommentare. Manfred ist nach vorne
-gegangen. Warum?
-Ich bin deshalb nach vorne gegangen, weil
die beiden Beiträge von Stephan und auch von dir
aus meiner Sicht in vielerlei
Hinsicht berechtigt sind. Bei dir
gefällt mir dieser Ansatz, dass du sagst,
wir müssen das global lösen,
dieses Problem. Und da bin ich ganz bei dir.
Wir müssen tatsächlich darauf
achtgeben, dass jene, die auch benachteiligt waren,
nicht zuletzt aus der Geschichte - und ich muss
das nicht alles wiederholen, was du
gesagt hast, weil da war ja auch vieles
richtig - dass da auch reagiert wird.
Und ich glaube, da wird auch reagiert,
weil es kann auch nicht sein,
dass ein Impfstoff, der beispielsweise
in Europa 20 Euro pro Impfdosis kostet.
Ich sage mal, der Preis ist, der in Südafrika,
in Tunesien oder in Ägypten
aufgerufen wird oder in anderen
Ländern auf dieser Welt.
Wobei man ja sagen muss, dass Astrazeneca
auch noch teurer verkauft wurde- Ja,
aber es gibt aber auch und das ist
auch eine Wahrheit ja bereits jetzt schon
belastbare Abmachungen, wonach
qualitativ hochwertige Impfstoffe,
die auch in ausreichender Menge zur Verfügung
stehen, zu günstigen Preisen
angeboten werden. Ich glaube nicht,
dass wir das Problem- Wir müssen aufpassen,
dass wir nicht eine falsche
Diskussion führen. Patentschutz hat uns
die Impfstoffe gebracht und wir brauchen
jetzt und da hast du hundertprozentig
recht, eine globale Lösung. Aber
sorgen wir doch da gemeinsam dafür,
dass wir ich sage einmal, ich nenne
jetzt Afrika, eine Situation schaffen,
wo tatsächlich Plattformen
entstehen, die auch in Zukunft sicherstellen,
dass Impfstoffe vor Ort
zuverlässig hergestellt werden. Das betrachte
ich als unsere Aufgabe. Da sollten
wir viel investieren, auch in politischen
Gesprächen, in Abmachungen und und und.
Ich habe das Gefühl, da geht
was in die richtige Richtung.
Aber ich glaube zu sagen Patentschutz weg
und das Problem ist
gelöst, das ist nicht der Fall.
Aber dann erkläre- Ich will nur die Position
noch einmal klarmachen,
dann könnte ihr sofort dagegen
schießen. Nehmen wir doch mal an, wir leben
in einer anderen Welt und der Patentschutz
würde jetzt fallen, als Ausnahmeregelung
wegen der aktuellen weltweiten
Notlage. Dann glaubst du ja trotzdem nicht,
dass genügend Impfstoff bei den Menschen
ankommt, die brauchen. Warum nicht?
Weil wir es sehen. Und dafür gibt es belastbare
Daten, dass es nicht so einfach
ist. Um ein Beispiel zu nennen
einen: mRNA Impfstoff, der sehr labil ist
aufgrund seiner Konstitution
gekühlt von der Produktion bis ich sage mal
zum Impfling zu bringen Diese Strukturen
müssen verbessert und sichergestellt
werden. Und wenn wir das haben, können
wir verfügbaren Impfstoff sofort releasen
-und zu den Menschen bringen.
-Jetzt sind beide nach hinten gegangen.
Warum? Unbeabsichtigt- Nein, also ich bin
fundamental nicht der Meinung, dass uns
Patente die Impfstoffe gebracht
haben. Wenn wir noch mal auf die HIV-Aids-Krise
Anfang der 2000er zurückschauen. Da sind
Millionen von Menschen gestorben,
täglich 100000 Menschen im südlichen
Afrika, die sich die Behandlung, die 10000
US-Dollar pro Patient pro Jahr
gekostet haben, nicht leisten konnten. Und was war
da der entscheidende Gamechanger? Es war
der Wettbewerb mit Generika, die in Indien
hergestellt wurden, weil Indien noch
nicht das Patentsystem umsetzen musste.
Das heißt, es konnten- Die Preise
sind bis auf 100, ungefähr 100 US-Dollar pro
Patient pro Jahr gesunken.
Sie wurden dadurch mehr zugänglich,
weil sie günstiger wurden. Aber
dieser Wettbewerb hat auch Innovationen
gefördert. Bei der HIV-Aids-Therapie
muss man klassischerweise drei verschiedene
Medikamente nehmen. Was aus Indien
dann gekommen ist und das war wirklich
eine Innovation, ist, dass diese dreifache
Therapie tatsächlich in einer Pille
vereinfacht wurde. Und das war
eine Innovation, die nicht über
den Patentschutz gekommen ist, sondern die tatsächlich
im Endeffekt hervorgebracht
wurde durch einen Wettbewerb und weil es gar
keine Anreize gab für westliche
Firmen, sich damit zu beschäftigen
eine solche Pille, eine solche Innovation
für die Menschen, die leider nicht
genug Kaufkraft haben, zu entwickeln. In Indien
waren aber diese Anreize da, weil sie gesehen
haben, wir machen lieber
mit der Masse der Menschen Geld, die uns
brauchen, anstatt auf wenige Reiche
zu setzen. Also das Argument ist
fehlender Patentschutz kann auch Innovationen
hervorbringen. Ja, haben wir gesehen.
In dem Fall ist es plausibel.
Wobei, ein bisschen verwechselst du
Äpfel mit Birnen und zwar deshalb, weil- es ist
alles richtig, was du gesagt
hast. Nur müsste man auch dazusagen,
dass die Herstellung dieser Arzneimittel
gegen HIV/Aids natürlich auch komplex ist,
aber in der Komplexität nicht
vergleichbar sind mit der Herstellung eines
mRNA-Impfstoffes. Das heißt alleine
zu sagen: Ich lass jetzt das Patent fallen
und jeder kann machen mit dem Patent
was er will, ist nicht so einfach,
weil die Produktion dieses Impfstoffes
ist wirklich schwierig, da braucht man
wirklich viel Know how und es wäre
niemandem geholfen, keinem Impfling
dieser Welt, würden wir Impfstoffe
produzieren, die nicht den Erfordernissen
entsprechen, die wir an Impfstoffe
stellen.
Aber das heißt, du schließt komplett
aus, dass man außerhalb von Europa oder USA
Impfstoffe herstellen kann,
die diesen Ansprüchen genügen?
Nein, das schließe ich nicht aus, aber
die notwendigen Voraussetzungen dafür müssen
gegeben sein. Wir brauchen
natürlich ein System, wo der, der herstellt,
auch kontrolliert wird. Ja, das ist
ein ganz entscheidendes Element. Es ist ja,
wenn man sich heute ansieht,
wie nach einem gültigen europäischen
Arzneimittelrecht Impfstoffe
hergestellt werden, dann ist das wirklich ein System,
das einer strengen Kontrolle
unterliegt. Ich will nicht, ich sage mal, mit einem
Impfstoff geimpft werden, der in einem
Land hergestellt wird, wo irgendein
Potentat sozusagen sagt: Ich nutze
jetzt auch das freigegebene Patent und mache
jetzt auch Impfstoffe, die in der Qualität
nicht entsprechen, wo keiner mehr
-kontrollieren kann, was Sache ist.
-Du bist gleich dran, aber erst bist du
-dran.
-Ich will es nur noch mal einbringen, weil
ich glaube, dass es auch einfach
wichtig ist, nicht aus dem Blick zu verlieren.
Oder andersherum Ich frag dich,
verhindert denn die Freigabe von Patenten,
dass Technologietransfer
passiert? Also das klingt immer nach so einem
entweder oder. Und ich glaube wir sind
uns hier alle einig, dass die Patentfreigabe
nicht das einzige ist. Es ist ein Schritt.
Du hast es als ein Instrument von sehr,
sehr vielen bezeichnet. Und die Frage
ist oder meine Frage an dich. Ich weiß nicht,
ob ich die stellen darf ist. Was glaubst
du denn, was passiert, wenn die Patente
freigegeben werden mit Bezug auf diesen notwendigen
Technologietransfer,
-von dem wir alle sprechen?
-Ich glaube, da sind wir sofort einer
Meinung. Also ich bin dafür, die Patente
sozusagen so zu belassen, wie sie sind.
Aber ich bin auch dafür und da bin
ich hundertprozentig bei dir, dass wir alles
daran setzen,
Technologietransfer zu betreiben.
Jetzt ist Bernhard die ganze
Zeit schon am Scharren.
Ja, jetzt kommen wir an den Punkt:
Reicht es, auf die freiwillige Kooperation
der Unternehmen zu setzen oder müssen
wir das eben zwangsweise machen? Und das ist,
glaube ich, der einzige, vielleicht
nicht der einzige, aber der Hauptpunkt,
wo wir unterschiedlich sind. Und weil wir die Kooperation
der Unternehmen
aus unserer Sicht brauchen und weil wir Unternehmertum
brauchen- Wir brauchen
diesen Forschergeist, das,
wofür die Leute ausgezeichnet werden
mit Bundesverdienstkreuzen. Ja,
will ich auch nochmal erinnern daran,
was wir einerseits würdigen, können
wir doch nicht durch den enteignungsgleichen
Eingriff, so sagen die Juristen
dann - kompliziertes Wort, aber so ist es -
den enteignungensgleichen
Eingriff dann auch unterlaufen.
Ich glaube es ist auch völlig
unstrittig. Niemand will jetzt BioNTech ans Bein
pinkeln. Im Gegenteil, alle sind
ganz froh, dass diese gute Forschung
in Deutschland vonstatten ging.
Wer weiß, wo wir stünden, wenn es so
was wie bei BioNTech gegeben hätte.
Weltweit auch gesehen. Ich glaube, das ist
unstrittig. Aber du hast jetzt
natürlich einen heiklen Punkt anggesprochen.
Allein der Begriff
enteignungsgleicher- Eingriff. -Eingriffe, da bist du ja
-zurückgeschreckt.
-Das stimmt einfach nicht. Also sozusagen
das, was auf dem Tisch liegt, wäre
keine Enteignung. Nochmals der Markt.
Natürlich- Die finanzstarken Märkte
wären für alle Firmen, die derzeit produzieren,
gesichert. Also ist jetzt nicht so,
dass dann hier in Deutschland irgendwo dann
auf einmal ein Wettbewerb besteht
und wir Angst haben müssten, das BioNTech
-sozusagen-
-Aber er hat recht. Es geht um einen harten
-Eingriff in die unternehmerische Freiheit.
-Das beste Mittel wäre, wenn wirklich alle
Firmen sagen: Wir geben die Technologien
weiter, wir transferieren es, wir arbeiten
mit allen zusammen, die, die es wollen
und dann werden auch die Qualitätsstandards
gehalten. Aber wie gesagt, wir sehen
das jetzt, dass diese Impfstoffe seit über
einem Jahr existieren und ist
noch nicht genug passiert. Wir sind
bei durchschnittlich zehn Prozent
geimpfter Menschen auf dem afrikanischen
Kontinent. Es ist zu wenig. Ich glaube,
dass wir nicht mit Freiwilligkeit,
nicht sozusagen den Schritt
machen, den wir machen müssen. Und wir reden
auch nur über eine kurze Zeit,
hoffentlich kurze Zeit, bis diese Pandemie beendet
-ist.
-Also jetzt wissen wir- Wir werden gleich
noch ein bisschen weiter springen.
Aber Manfred ist auch schon am Zucken
und für dich einmal die Frage
rüber gespiegelt. Also kannst du dir
ein Szenario vorstellen, nehmen wir an,
die Impfstoffverteilung läuft weiter
schlecht. Wir leben in einem halben
Jahr immer noch in einer Welt, in der viel
zu wenig Menschen geimpft sind. Kannst
du dir vorstellen, dass auch du irgendwann
zu einem Punkt kommst, wo du sagst
ein enteignungsgleicher Eingriff bzw.
andere sagen ein milder
Eingriff in die unternehmerische Freiheit,
ohne dass irgendjemand
davon arm wird, ist vorstellbar?
Ich will zunächst darauf setzen, dass man
das auch im Sinne von freiwilligen Tun
erreicht. Und ich bin mir sehr sicher,
dass das an der Stelle auch funktionieren
-wird.
-Wir haben es kurz angerissen. Es ging um
öffentliche Gelder. Die große
Frage zum Beispiel. Wir nehmen das jetzt
nur als Beispiel Firma, es ist tut mir
leid, aber das kennen halt alle: BioNTech
hat ungefähr 400 Millionen Euro von von der öffentlichen
Hand bekommen, das heißt
von uns allen Steuergeld, um das Ganze
zum Fliegen zu bringen. Da gibt
es die Argumentation: Na ja, wenn wir uns
daran zumindest in geringem Maße beteiligt
haben, warum kann dann die Firma
nicht ein bisschen was zur Allgemeinheit
zurückgeben? Habe ich das vorhin
richtig verstanden?
Unter anderem ja und auch zu sagen,
dass nur aufgrund der erwarteten Gewinne durch
die Monopolstellung, die durch
Patente geschaffen wird, dass nur das Forschung
und Entwicklung sozusagen Anreize
setzt, dem würde ich widersprechen. Viel
der Grundlagenforschung wird
öffentlich finanziert und in diesem Fall wurde
tatsächlich auch von der öffentlichen
Hand ein Unternehmen, das jetzt Vaccine
herstellt und ein Patent hat,
auch finanziert oder unterstützt.
-Kannst du das nachvollziehen?
-Na klar. Der Gedanke liegt nahe, das würde
aber bedeuten, dass wir überall, wo wir fördern,
auch den Zugriff auf die Patente
und mit der Förderung praktisch
verkaufen. Und das ist, glaube ich kontraproduktiv.
Wir alle wollen Forschung um der Forschung
und der Forschungsergebnisse willen,
aber wir wollen nicht damit
den Zugriff auf das Unternehmen.
Evein ist so ein Stückchen
zurückgegangen, habe ich beim gemerkt. Wem gehören
-die Patente deiner Meinung nach?
-Ja, ich bin zurückgegangen, als du überall
gesagt hast. Im Sinne von überall, wo die öffentliche
Hand was reingeht, möchte
sie dann auch Anteile am Patentrecht
haben. Da bin ich sehr, sehr weit
zurückgegangen. Nochmal, wir sprechen
ja nicht von überall und immer,
sondern wir sprechen von einer globalen
Notsituation und von einem temporären
Aussetzen dieser Patente, bis diese Situation
hoffentlich bald vorbei ist.
Und um noch einmal deine Frage
genauer zu beantworten. Ich glaube schon,
dass wenn sehr, sehr viele Gelder aus der öffentlichen
Hand kommen, da auch immer
die Frage ist, woran wird sich
orientiert? Also wird sich eben orientiert - hatten
wir vorhin: Menschenrechte,
Gesundheit, Globale Verantwortung - Wo liegt
das Interesse? Vor allen Dingen
wer bestimmt, wo dieses Interesse liegt
und wer entscheidet, wo dieses Interesse
liegt? Und ich glaube, wenn eben
die öffentliche Hand, somit der Steuerzahler
und der Staat sich stärker
einbringen, sollten auch Interessen des
globalen Südens eine größere Rolle spielen
und eben nicht alleine
Innovation und Pharmaindustrie.
Manfred! Ich glaube, hier wird
vergessen, dass das Unternehmen das Mainzer
Unternehmen- ich habe gar keine
Zweifel, dass der öffentliche Mittel geflossen
sind, allerdings zu einem Zeitpunkt,
wo der Impfstoff schon da war. Das wollen
wir schon an der Stelle festhalten,
wenn man das Steueraufkommen des einzelnen
-Unternehmens betrachtet.
-Entschuldigung, ganz, ganz kurz: BioNTech
wurde schon ganz am Anfang auch vom Bundesministerium
für Forschung gefördert,
mit ein paar Millionen, ich glaube
vier oder fünf Millionen. Und als dann
der Impfstoff mehr oder weniger
da waren, flossen noch mal 380.
Ja, aber es ist auch eine Wahrheit,
dass das Unternehmen im Grunde am Abgrund
stand. Und das war das Investment
der Brüder Andreas und Thomas Strüngmann,
die letztendlich dieses Unternehmen am Leben
gehalten haben. Zu einem Zeitpunkt,
wo noch nicht über die Frage des
Corona-Impfstoffes gesprochen wurde,
sondern da ging es noch um die Tumor-Impfstoffe.
Wenn dieses Investment
nicht gekommen wäre, hätte es das Unternehmen
mit der Technologie
-in der Folge nicht gegeben.
-Das heiß die 400 Millionen hätte man gar
nicht investiert? Die hätte man
nicht investieren können, weil dann wäre
das Unternehmen nicht mehr da gewesen.
Aber war das jetzt eine gute
oder eine schlechte
staatliche Investition?
Ich kenne jetzt nicht das Ausmaß
der der Subventionen oder Unterstützungen,
wann die passiert sind. Aber ich weiß
eines, dass das Unternehmen ja
vor der Situation stand, zuzumachen
oder einen neuen Geldgeber zu bekommen.
Und jetzt will ich eigentlich das sagen,
was ich vorhin schon sagen wollte.
Die Steuereinnahmen dieses Unternehmens,
die Steuerabgaben, die sind so enorm,
dass die Stadt Mainz
sich freuen wie ein Schneekönig.
Schwarze Zahlen auf einmal. Die sind
jetzt in den schwarzen Zahlen auf einmal.
Die sind in den schwarzen Zahlen ist.
Man darf jetzt nicht so tun. Es würde hier
kein Rückfluss sein. Das Unternehmen
gibt auch erheblich zurück.
Du hast natürlich vollkommen recht. Vor allem
in der Pharmabranche spielen private
Investitionen die größte Rolle.
Ganz eindeutig. Prozentual gesehen ist
es eindeutig so. Nun ist es aber
Fakt, dass wir 400 Millionen Euro Steuergeld
in zum Beispiel BioNTech
reingeschlagen haben und die Frage war ja, hat da nicht
die Allgemeinheit vielleicht doch
zumindest ein kleines Mitspracherecht,
wenn es um Verantwortung in der Welt
geht? Du hast deine Meinung schon gesagt-
Ich glaube ein Mitspracherecht im Sinne
von: Du musst jetzt ein Patent aufgeben,
nicht. Aber natürlich - und wir machen
das hier ja im Grunde auch, dass wir einen
Dialog darüber führen, wie können
wir das Problem lösen? Es ist ja nicht so,
dass wir in der globalen Frage
auseinander sind. Wir alle wollen die Covid-Krise
überwinden. Das ist der Punkt. Aber
es ist nicht das Patent, der Patentschutz,
das Problem, sondern andere
Probleme müssen gelöst werden. Die müssen
-angegangen werden.
-Wolltest du noch? Ich glaube schon, dass
es ein Hindernis- Und noch mal:
Patente sind wichtig. Ich glaube nicht,
dass wir die Patentschutz und das System
abschaffen sollten. Nur es gibt hier
und da Situationen, wo er uns nicht
hilft, wo er auch sozusagen für die öffentliche
Gesundheit tatsächlich vielleicht
nicht die beste Lösung ist. Es gibt weltweit
Produktionsstätten, die auch mRNA
Impfstoffe herstellen könnten
zu der Qualität, die wir haben
wollen. Aber jetzt ist natürlich- Es gibt keine
Investoren, die sagen wir mal,
die notwendigen Investitionen,
die auch in diesen Produktionskapazitäten
noch getätigt werden müssten-
Diese Investitionen kommen nicht,
weil ja immer noch nicht klar ist dürfen
die überhaupt produzieren. Ich glaube,
wenn man sagen würde, wir folgen
diesem Vorschlag, der von über 100
Staaten der Welt und den Vereinigten Staaten
unterstützt wird und geben die Patente
auf Medikamente, Impfstoffe und so weiter frei
im Bezug auf die Corona-Pandemie,
dann würden wir Investoren sehen,
die tatsächlich in diese Produktionskapazitäten
investieren würden
und die nötigen Anpassungen
somit finanzieren würden. Aber Bernhards
Argument ist ja, noch nicht mal als Ultima
Ratio kann man noch nicht mal zeitlich
begrenzt Patente freigeben, weil man
das Vertrauen in den Patentschutz dermaßen
beschädigt, dass wir uns damit das nächste
und vielleicht viel größere Problem
-einhandeln.
-Deswegen gehe ich einen Schritt auf ihn
zu, weil also ultima Ratio, am Ende
ist es vielleicht doch ein Instrument.
Und da sagen wir auch- Also wir setzen
auf die freiwillige Kooperation.
Wenn das jetzt nicht kommt, dann
müssen wir das noch mal uns genau angucken.
Kurze Frage: Wie lange willst du
noch gucken? 2022 und dann? Oder? Ja, 2022.
Also ich würde sagen ja, wir können
die Sendung gerne in einem halben Jahr
-wiederholen.
-Halbes Jahr ist eine gute Frist. Wie geht
es euch nach dieser Diskussion?
Könntet ihr euch vorstellen, wenn ihr am Drücker
säßt? Ihr dürftet entscheiden! Könntet
ihr euch vorstellen, Patente freizugeben?
Als allerletztes Mittel, so wie es Bernhard
formuliert, oder als sogar
vorvorletztes Mittel, so wie es die grüne
Seite formuliert? Gerade könnte ihr euch
das vorstellen? Ja oder nein?
Warum ist das so? Also begründet gerne
eure Entscheidung und schreibt's uns in die Kommentaren.
Ich würde ganz gerne noch
mal Manfred dazu holen mit einem
neuen Twist. Es gibt ja einen vielleicht neuen
Impfstoff namens Corbevax.
Erforscht in Texas, ein sogenannter Open Source
Impfstoff, der mit Absicht eben
nicht patentiert wurde, damit er freigegeben
werden kann. Es ist noch nicht ganz
klar, wie wirksam er ist, aber offenbar erste
Studien zeigen auf meine hohe
Wirksamkeit bei gleichzeitig sehr günstiger
und einfacher Produktion. Das Ganze
hat angeblich gekostet neun Millionen Euro
Privat Geld, also vergleichsweise
gar nichts. Ist das nun nicht der Beweis,
dass, wenn man Impfstoffe von der Profitorientierung
abkoppeln, sie doch
-für alle zugänglich sein könnten?
-Ich glaube, dass es gut ist, dass wir
zunächst einmal diese Technologie,
die schon sehr alt ist, auch einsetzen,
um Impfstoffe zu entwickeln.
Dass das jetzt freigegeben wird, finde
ich auch in Ordnung. Diese Impfstoffe,
von denen du jetzt gesprochen hast, also
diese rekombinanten, proteinbasierten
Arzneistoffe, die sind deshalb eine Chance
auch für die gesamte Welt, weil sie auch leichter
hergestellt werden können.
Diese Technologie kann man viel
leichter auch in weniger industrialisierten Ländern
herstellen. Deshalb ist alles daran zu setzen,
dass das auch vorangetrieben wird.
Ich warne davor zu sagen, dass das jetzt
sozusagen das allein seligmachende ist.
Gerade bei diesem konkreten Beispiel
mit Blick auf das, was wir uns wünschen
wirksame, sichere und in der pharmazeutischen
Qualität
auch entsprechende Impfstoffe zu haben.
Mir fehlen da noch viele klinische Daten,
die tatsächlich belegen, dass die Wirksamkeit
da ist. Aber grundsätzlich ist
gegen diese Entwicklung nichts zu sagen,
weil es auch ein wichtiger Schritt ist,
um die Pandemie zu bekämpfen. Aber
die Qualitätsstandards sollten in allen
Belangen, die ich genannt
habe, eingehalten.
Okay, jetzt haben wir ein paar
sehr konstruktive Vorschläge schon
ausgetauscht. Ihr steht auch relativ
weit vorne. Alle. Manfred ist so auf halber
Höhe, noch nicht ganz vorne, ist aber
auch gar nicht schlimm. Jeder darf hier stehen,
wo er will oder wo sie will. Wir wollen
jetzt in die Kompromissrunde gehen.
Ich mache mal einen einen
Kompromissvorschlag, der sagt,
wenn der Staat wie zum Beispiel im Falle
von BioNTech eine gehörige Menge Geld
in die Hand nimmt. Und es geht
um Gesundheits Produkte.
Und zu diesem Zeitpunkt wusste man
auch wir laufen in eine Pandemie rein.
Wir nehmen ganz viel Geld in die Hand
und machen uns vertraglich ein ganz kleines
Hintertürchen. Wir kommen in eine Notlage,
wie wir sie jetzt haben. Dann hätten
wir so eine Art Vorkaufsrecht auf eine Lizenz
zum Beispiel. Niemand soll dabei
arm werden. Also BioNTech schon mal
gar nicht. Und auch die ganzen Zulieferer
nicht. Aber wir hätten eine kleine
Chance zu sagen Wir schnappen uns jetzt drei,
vier Lizenzen und geben sie günstig
weiter in die Welt. Das ist
der Kompromissvorschlag. Wenn ihr sagt:
Finde ich gar nicht so schlecht, würde
ich den Schritt vorgehen. Oder wenn ihr sagt
kann ich nix mit anfangen, bleib hier
stehen oder geht sogar
zurück. Bernhard geht nach vorne.
-Ich gehe nach vorn-
-Du gehst so halb nach vorn.
-weil da natürlich der Konsens
drinsteckt, das Unternehmen, was die Fördermittel
annimmt, muss sich ja und hat
Juristen, die sich die Verträge durchlesen.
Und wenn sie mit dieser Bedingung
einverstanden sind, dann sind
sie freiwillig dabei. Das ist ein Geben
und Nehmen. Und das ist für mich
das Entscheidende, dass es eben
konsensual in einer in einer Partnerschaft ist.
Es ist ein ultra komplexer
Vertrag, den man aufsetzen müsste.
Ist er wahrscheinlich so oder so und dann
kommt da halt noch eine Seite mehr drauf
und da steht das drin. Und das ist,
wenn es im Vertrag geregelt ist, total
-in Ordnung.
-Gut, du bist auch so ein bisschen nach
vorne gegangen. Wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Du findest das nicht so gut. Warum nicht?
Ja, ich hänge einfach auch noch
mal an diesem Aspekt von Konsens
und mit der Frage, wer eben den bestimmt
und wessen Interessen da im Vordergrund
stehen. Und noch mal: Wir sprechen
heute wirklich über die globale Perspektive,
nicht ausschließlich über die deutsche.
Deshalb bin ich mir nicht sicher,
inwiefern praktisch ein Konsens
basierend auf den Interessen eines deutschen Staates
und eines deutschen Unternehmens
wirklich die globale Perspektive im Blick behalten
-kann.
-Fair enough. Fair enough, So, jetzt seid
ihr dran. Jeweils, steckt doch
mal ein bisschen die Köpfe zusammen.
Coronagerecht natürlich, also jeweils
in euren Gruppen. Denkt euch mal 2 3 Minuten
was aus. Vielleicht einen Satz,
einen Vorschlag, womit ihr die anderen
überzeugen könntet. Merkt euch bitte
eure Position, damit wir ungefähr wissen,
wo wir waren. Und jetzt geht's los.
-sofort Ideen haben. Spannende Diskussion,
wie immer. Was würdet ihr denn sagen,
habt ihr aus dieser Diskussion heraus eine Idee
entwickelt, wo ihr sagt, hier würden
die beiden Seiten noch enger zusammenkommen.
Das wäre vielleicht eine Lösung
auch für zukünftige Pandemien. Dann schreib
es gerne in die Kommentare. Ihr könnt
ja auch noch mal eine halbe Sekunde über
den Vorschlag nachdenken, den ihr gleich
formulieren wollt, denn die gelbe Seite
steht schon länger bereit. Also gelb,
was ist euer Vorschlag? Wie schafft ihr es,
-dass die beiden näher auf euch zukommen?
-Also wir sind uns absolut einig, dass wir
ganz viel gleichzeitig tun müssen, um mehr
Impfstoff weltweit zu verteilen, das ist
das unbestrittene Ziel. Und dazu
müssen wir wie gesagt, mehr Impfstoffe
in die internationalen
Verteilungsmechanismus wie Covax geben.
Wir müssen auch mehr
Produktionsstätten aufbauen. Dazu setzen wir immer noch
auf Kooperation mit der Industrie
und auf Unterstützung der Systeme vor Ort
und wo wir nicht ganz beieinander
sind. Ich habe ja eben schon gesagt, wir würden
uns das einen bestimmten Zeitraum
noch angucken und müssen dann evaluieren,
ob wir mit der Freiwilligkeit wirklich
zum Ergebnis kommen. Und wenn wir merken,
dass die Unternehmen nicht mitziehen,
dann müssen wir vielleicht noch mal über
-diese Frage gesondert nachdenken.
-Da bist du nicht ganz einig. Du bist
-radikal dagegen, richtig?
-Ich bin jetzt nicht gegen diese
Vorschläge. Ich sage nur, dass der Patentschutz
nicht das Problem ist,
sondern wir haben andere Probleme,
die gelöst werden müssen. Dass wir hier
in einem Boot sitzen und nicht
sozusagen alleine agieren können, ist auch völlig
klar. Wir müssen
solidarisch agieren, weltweit.
Ich glaube, ich muss das einfach vor unserem
Konsens noch mal sagen, weil du
ganz klar gesagt hast, dass Patentschutz
und das Patentrecht nicht das Problem ist.
Und ich glaube, wir sind uns einig,
dass Patente nicht die einzige Lösung sind.
Aber auch diese Pandemie
ist nicht die letzte und es gibt
auch nach wie vor andere Krankheiten,
über die wir blendend sprechen könnten, wo eben
doch das Patentrecht mit eine Verantwortung
irgendwo hat dafür,
-dass wir da sind, wo wir sind.
-Okay, was ist euer Vorschlag? Wie kommen
wir möglichst schnell aus dieser Pandemie
heraus? Und da denke ich, sollten
wir tatsächlich als- Sollte die Bundesregierung,
sollte die Europäische
Kommission sollte die Regierung
der Vereinigten Staaten und alle anderen
einfach tatsächlich die Privatindustrie
in die Verantwortung nehmen und sagen: Liebe
Freundinnen und Freunde, ihr schafft
jetzt in den nächsten drei bis sechs Monaten
die Voraussetzungen, dass wir gar
nicht mehr über diesen TRIPS-Waiver reden
müssen. Wenn das aber nicht passiert,
dann reden wir über den TRIPS-Waiver und dann
kommt der, weil so kann es einfach
nicht weitergehen. Es ist nicht mehr möglich,
dass wir business as usual machen. Und da hat
die Privatindustrie ihre Verantwortung
-zu tragen.
-Und ich fasse jetzt mal zusammen, ob ich
dich richtig verstanden habe:
Eigentlich ist es doch relativ einfach, was du sagst.
Industrie! Achtung! Wenn ihr keinen
TRIPS- Waiver wollt, löst das Problem.
So schnell wie möglich. Also
eigentlich eine Androhung? Ja, schon, weil wir uns
-in einer Notlage befinden!
-Ja, ich will ja nur verstehen, habe ich
richtig verstanden? Gut, ihr beiden
habt ja so ganz ähnliche Sachen eigentlich
-gesagt.
-Du bist nach vorne gegangen, ich bin nach
vorne gegangen. Ich bin mit 99%
einverstanden. Ich bin total dabei,
dass die Industrie eine Verantwortung
hat. Das weiß die Industrie auch. Es gibt viele
Kooperationen, aber es muss
noch mehr geben. Und vor allem müssen
wir diese Ergebnisse sehen. Und in kurzer
Zeit. Ja, ich habe gemischte Gefühle.
Ich finde den Gedanken schön, dass es irgendwo
ein gleiches Ziel gibt. Aber
ich glaube schon, dass sie die Vorstellungen
der Wege, von uns beiden
zumindest, sich schon so
ein Stück weit unterscheiden.
Ich glaube, das, was ich heute
gelernt habe, war auch, dass wir sozusagen
bei der Bewertung der aktuellen
Situation beispielsweise die Geschichte nicht außer
Acht lassen dürfen. Das hast du ja sehr stark
eingebracht. Und ich finde, das sind
Aspekte, die die müssen wir ernst
nehmen. Und ich gebe ehrlich zu, vor der Sendung
habe ich mir darüber nicht so viele
Gedanken gemacht. Jetzt nach der Sendung
mache ich mir da mehr Gedanken, weil es ist
nur dann die Sache wirklich lösbar,
-wenn wir diese Aspekte mitnehmen.
-Eigentlich sind wir nur an einer Stelle
noch auseinander, nämlich wie lange
geben wir der Industrie Zeit, das Problem
mit ihren Mitteln in Partnerschaft
zu lösen? Ja, das war ein sehr gutes
Gespräch, sehr gute Diskussion. Ja,
ich kann das nur zurückgeben. Ich fand
generell, die Diskussion war
auf einem sehr hohen Niveau. Wir haben
sehr konstruktiv miteinander
gesprochen, haben durchaus auch unterschiedliche
Standpunkte vertreten, das war uns
klar. Aber schön und wichtig ist tatsächlich
meiner Meinung nach gewesen, was rauskam,
dass wir alle ein Ziel haben
und dass das überhaupt nicht
hinterfragt wird, dass wir diese Pandemie so schnell
wie möglich beenden müssen. Und dass der Weg
dazu ist, tatsächlich allen Menschen
weltweit Zugang zu Impfstoffen
zu gewähren.
Herzlichen Dank für diese Diskussion.
Wenn ihr jetzt zu Hause sagt: Mensch, ich hab
richtig was gelernt, schreibt's in die Kommentare
oder wenn ihr sagt alle vier
liegen komplett falsch, auch das könnt
ihr gerne hinterlassen. Ganz herzlichen Dank!
Die 13 Fragen zu Impfpatente
freigeben, ja oder nein?
-Danke, danke!
Ich denke, es ist klar geworden, wer behauptet, die einen wollen Menschenleben retten und die anderen wollen nur
Profite maximieren, der macht es sich etwas zu einfach.
Die Diskussion ist um einiges
komplexer. Auf der anderen
Seite sehen wir, die internationale
Staatengemeinschaft hat bei der Impfstoff
Verteilung Probleme.
Prinzip Freiwilligkeit zieht
offenbar nicht ganz. Ich persönlich glaube,
Staaten sollten durchaus in die Lage
versetzt werden, zumindest milde,
zumindest in diesen weltweiten
Ausnahmesituationen stärker in den Markt
eingreifen zu können. Wenn euch 13
Fragen gefällt, dann könnt ihr hier unseren Kanal
abonnieren. Hier gibt es eine weitere
Folge und hier gibt es ein weiteres Video
zum Thema.